well as far as i can
understand the mdma would be more for
the cognitive behavioral therapy
route where you just get them to relive
their memory
and then now with the mdma they can't
feel the fear as much in fact they might
attach positive emotions to it
whereas with your treatment it's like
please don't attach any positive
emotions
feel the fear so that's why with lsd
that's completely different lsd it's not
like
you're only experiencing euphoria if
you're you can have the most intense
anxiety attacks of your entire life
so do you imagine the treatment with lsd
would be i i would imagine it would be
much different than mdma i
don't i would imagine that lsd or
mushrooms would be more in line with
your treatment rather than mdma which is
cognitive behavioral therapy a cognitive
behavioral
therapy accelerator is mdma your
treatment accelerator might be
lsd that's what i surmise but i want to
know what you think
yeah i agree because
yeah because mdma uh also triggers an
i think an oxytocin uh release if i uh
yeah
um
so it could be sort of somehow inhibits
the um
yeah it could you're allowed to
speculate don't worry it could
work in two directions because it could
also help
if you feel safe and attached for
instance to your therapist it could also
help
to dive into your also in
into the trauma memory and into the more
difficult
emotions so in that sense and mdma
would also work because if you are too
if the emotions are too strong it could
also at a certain point sort of
yeah inhibits of really going
into into it and feeling it
the documentary you mentioned is called
cure of fear is that correct
yeah okay i recommend everyone watch
this this i watched it
i found it endlessly fascinating it's
what turned me onto your research to
begin with
is there something else you do
afterwards after the post for your
stimulus
other than just give them the beta
blocker do you talk them down you say
everything will be okay
is there or is it is it as simple as
expose yourself to the fear 10 out of 10
take the beta blocker five minutes after
that or
or pretty much immediately after that
and go
along with your day have a nice rest is
there something else that's missing
no so so i mean the
the exposure is is is not so easy
i mean that is really difficult people
are generally not able to do it
themselves because they really need
support
to actually do it because the fear
response itself
triggers an avoidance response so they
want to
to escape the situation of course but if
they have done so
no then they go to a room uh what we do
is um
only i mean i briefly reinforce them for
what they did
so far and then they wait for two hours
they relax uh because we want to make
sure that
they don't have another stressful
experience that could
trigger another nor adrenaline response
it could interfere with
the effect of the beta blocker
okay so and then after two hours they go
home
have a night of sleep and then they come
back
for a test so you're there
in part to make sure that they don't
have another traumatic experience that
worsens it completely because i would
imagine that this could drive someone
insane if they're exposed to 10 out of
10 of fear on something that they're
already extremely afraid of
yeah so um so we we try to make sure
that they are not re-exposed
to uh to the feared cue and sometimes
it's difficult for instance we also
treat people with fear of dogs and then
when they go outside it could be that
they
will meet a dog again and yeah because
then
because we know that i mean that could
trigger again the fear memory
and we don't know but it makes sense
that then interferes with the
treatment effect so we always make sure
if that is the case
that someone will pick them up in the
car that they don't meet
a dog until a night of sleep and then
the next day
so we also once treated a woman with a
fear of
silver fish and they were at her house
so she was not allowed to
sleep in her own house she booked a
hotel
and then came back for the test and then
after
this first night she could go home again
to
to expose herself to the silver
fish when she was removed from the fear